a record number of people are expected
to hit the road over the fourth of July
holiday and today will be the busiest
day triple-a predicts 39 point 7 million
travelers will drive over this over the
holiday this year that's nearly two
million more than last year since July
4th is on a Wednesday many are planning
to start their weekend early Kris Van
Cleave is on the road on interstate 395
outside Washington DC Chris good morning
good morning this terrible Tuesday
traffic is expected to build as the day
goes on so it's starting to move now it
will slow way down come mid-afternoon
the peak time between 3:30 and 6:30 in
New York City you could see the drive
time more than double for a normal trip
the DC area will be close behind so will
Los Angeles triple-a estimates the
Independence Day travel season will be
the highest since it started tracking
holiday travel 18 years ago nearly 47
million people are expected to travel
the Auto Club believes a strong economy
and consumer confidence has left people
with disposable income that they are
using to travel and the increase comes
despite the highest gas prices for the
fourth of July since 2014 now gas prices
have ticked down a little bit since they
were flirting with $3 a gallon on
average over Memorial Day weekend but
there's still some 63 cents more than
they were last year in all right
all right wear your seatbelt there Kris
Van Cleave thank you so much